deux rondes c'est ce midi aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur montreux 26 ans
d'horreur en accès anticipé sur steam je
crois qu'on est dans un endroit et qu'on
doit s'échapper
voilà c'est tout ce que chez news
journal en tri tab à temps mais c'est
quoi c'est en supplie de mecs quoi ça me
donne le vomi aïe
ma tête me fait vraiment mal qu'est ce
qui se passe où je suis trouve ou tuer
et ont retrouvé ou d'actuels - dans un
placard bordel c'est pas bien ça comme
endroit la part de ce placard c'est un
casier mec mais c'est scandaleux ces
bruitages sont décodés ah ben voilà
ouais c'est exactement ce que j'allais
dire f to open jaws aux métaux la grèce
s'accroît le jeune l'agression on
l'appelle quoi pourrir ça oui monsieur
c'est quoi ça sert un verre d'eau que je
vais te casser contre un mur et ça
glousse tic au j'aime beaucoup
bordel c'est vrai maladie [ __ ] aux
grands des poursuites par avance si on
doit s'échapper par l'astuce que c'était
dur je vais le monde ne peut pas être
dans un petit casier comme ça c'est
juste pas possible non il y aura
problème de proportions un problème de
charisme surtout de la part de ce
monstre au journal of day they do et sur
un bateau voilà on est alors montre moi
un bateau comment j'ai fait pour me
retrouver ici doit y avoir un chemin
pour partir d'ici je ferais mieux de
regarder aux alentours
ab oui empêche pas vrai mais c'est pas
possible de casser les meilleurs
stylistes dégage c'est chiant j'espère
qu'à pas de monstre aubin voisins on se
casse
allez on dégage il est apparemment un
hélicoptère qui fonctionne sur le pont
ça pourrait être un bon moyen de son
chien oui j'ai besoin je suis terrifiée
je suis terrifiée c'est pas une blague
oh mais c'est vrai quoi la grèce dû
faire un max de bruit at et comprennent
très complexe avec les diables darwish
écrié je passe te sens-tu jeu mais
j'peux pas blanche plane et demain il
est terrifiant [ __ ] de bordel de merde
oui ok tu s'écrier d'accord c'est bien
de calais les commentaires il faut que
cherche de l'essence pour le pour le
chargé en essence et je trouve des clés
voilà et tout ça c'est sûr ce [ __ ] de
bâtons et jets de retrouver tout ça sans
mourir comme tous les [ __ ] de jeu
d'horreur qui font toujours flipper est
ce qu'ils se déplacent par rapport aux
sons elle il est terrifiant âgées hors
de ce monde soit allé on est content
scott maintenant il va nous défoncer
quare tel celui net c'est fini a plus
personne
la donne a quoi y'a j'aime un message
pour se cacher en fait à ôter demande
pas pourquoi je suis parti loin on va
aller bien on va lui il est bien où va
aller bien en bas voilà oh oh oh c'est
quoi il a été retenu et c'est ça pour ça
qu'on a vu ta main de son s'épanouir
mais est peut être à tout moment autour
de nous ah ça fait mal on l'a vu son
rayon [ __ ] il retire ses lunettes
rouges est un verbe boom tu as peur du
r1
on a les tâches moins 70 du bateau me
sens est sorti on a envie en pleine
santé ihome et attend des jumeaux rien
par des vagues de quoi au final c'est
les vols qui auront ma peau le monde
s'il est là pour nous prévenir justement
du vrai danger que sont les valves il
faut prendre ça et le jeter comme ça
nulle auquel il faut qu ici quoi comme
un joueur sont fait tuer s'il sera
question de joie en voyant ce monsieur
bordel ah oui c'est beau ça c'est sa
démarche lean on me maintenir en forme à
reims je suis capable de mettre cette
machine en marche
mais avant je dois ramener tout ça
howard launch console broken pas d'élan
au [ __ ] faut se cacher fausse cacher
nous a pas vus après je suis pas sûr les
champions beatbox aaa
voila voila demeure faible est bon on y
retourne c'est bien c'est bien parce que
quand on met on doit tout recommencer ça
me fait vraiment plaisir le plaisir
c'est quoi ça très bien c'est un fusible
voilà j'avais pas vu tout à l'heure donc
d'autres bannières on partait plutôt mal
autant se dire comment j'ouvre cette
porte comme un jour affolant ses
fusibles
c'est une blague c'est une banalité qu'à
six fusils mais là j'ai peur du gouffre
blood ce groupe et un non moins moi
cette pub on y adhère il faut il faut le
fusible que j'ai acheté vu un kit de
réparation mais oui jackson nous sommes
sur la bonne voie
oh c'est quoi ça une radio grecque
est ce que c'est pour l'activer
l'acheter à a pas pouvoir tester
mouillart il ouvre on lui met un coup de
radio direct attention grosse menace à
la radio
ça marche je pense que je mentais
mais c'est vrai que je veux juste vous
dire quoi je suis faible et maigrichon
faut faire le moins de bruit possible
vous avez compris en haute naissance
mecque pour les coachs au cameroun quand
on mouille à la culotte on le fait en
s'élançant je peux avoir la contacter
quelqu'un la halle au général oui armand
sera quelque peu obèses qui me tuer
bordel vous embêter les steaks dont vous
avez raison quand il est là il est là il
est là mon cher enfant je bois sous le
bureau je crois quelle erreur à l'on
porte aux testicules jusqu'au et des
hommes virils ou pas mais bien sûr les
hommes virils au le casier il est un bon
jour michel pour france 2 celui-ci les
caser le plus petit du monde voilà
reportage palpitant s il approche le
fusil ça veut dire je lui mets un
fusible dans la tête
nulle abc bons soient pas des ghettos
yoga shiatsu cascades et excité de la
narine l' intégrité du faisceau we both
yo ho non je vais jeter le faire dans
les yeux la police attend mais je pense
qu'elle va encore plus vite que toi et s
était une femme bon gars bah oui tu l'as
vu venir
non mais sans déconner il est hyper dur
ce jeu quoi je marche accroupis en
futurs élèves quand même à me trouver
avec gorges avec ce rayon nous le nul
moi j'aime bien l'idée d'aller plus haut
non on ne chantera pas cette chanson je
vous ai vu à un fusil mec c'est magique
à quelle époque n'hésitez pas à vous
réconforter dans le chat un but classés
par live voilà c'est j'avais envie dire
cette phrase nul en oui c'est quoi c'est
quoi ça ça fait un match de bruit mais
qu elle s est brûlant j'ai entendu on
aurait dit un mec qui mangeaient des
crânes chaque hôtel qui marche au petit
déj bordel oui monsieur qu'est ce que
c'est monsieur c'est un truc de
réparation c'est ça c'est magnifique
hu qu'est ce que c'est que ça tcbb ou si
son acné
mais le calme toi je cours je cours je
m'envole steg a les premières portes
j'apprends ont fait un mort une porte
oui la salle du sous marin oh oui par
ailleurs monsieur n'étions pas nous à
prendre l'avion d'un fusible voilà dans
un premier temps hop là il va juste ici
rien on vient de lancer la console
il faut réparer le panneau cassé
remplacer la batterie remplacer les
formes mais on s'en fout des femmes il
nous faut débattre il en faut trois
assez ça répare et oui monsieur
oui il faut qu'on trouve les batteries
et la lumière elle est allée chercher
des batteries on y va à une petite pièce
est dedans y'a quoi il ya toutes les
batteries avec non c'est la lumière
venue la lumière
il nous manquait les bacs d'eau à lienz
est cachée non paypal occupe vite le
casier on est dedans on est tranquille
je ne vois plus chier ceci est un sos
ça sert à rien si quelqu'un est
intéressé j'ai une chaîne et une pompe à
vélo
après ce que vous voulez quoi il parle
j'ai vu décerner match comme ça il
allait prendre son petit déj chez lui
que manger des craintes alors elle en
hiver je me chie dessus
terriblement voilà j'avais besoin de
partager ça avec vous là derrière la
batterie je le regarde et il ya de
l'essence oui ils sont pleins mais les a
bouffés les a bouffés le course pour
s'acquitter des bruits bizarres bah oui
on va dire et des batteries mon gars
c'est plein de plomb c'est toxique à
temps tialata vador [ __ ] jo au parfum
de la guitare ailleurs tu te calmes
quand un obscur bergé mais la radio elle
et quand faut y aller faut y aller on va
pas rester là 20 ans non plus le gros
enjeu bien qu'ils me tueraient d'un coup
mais alors lui c'est une blague quoi les
limites enfin poker je sais pas mais
matri doivent être en bas cette fameuse
pompe à vélo
non c'est là cela c'est là où il ya du
du spray antibiotiques non non regardez
la faiblesse de cet homme je meurs parce
que je me prends un spread de
désinfectant dans les yeux voilà allez
salut
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu
je suis pas du tout en colère parce que
vous croyez on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir
une gare des halles et à bientôt
cette fois ça y est au revoir pis aller
11 ans encore waldock
what enfants